e o meu filho Luca hoje tem seis anos e
meio tá quase fazendo 7 anos e os quatro
primeiros anos do Lucca foram vividos
comigo com Fernanda lá em Brasília e
Brasília é uma cidade que durante três
ou quatro meses do ano tem uma umidade
relativa do ar muito baixa e é natural
que nós temos uma pressão muito grande e
estarmos perto da água e o Luca ali nos
dois para três anos de idade ele adorava
nadar e após cirurgia para piscina fez
natação nos primeiros nos primeiros
momentos dele Finn e a escola incentiva
muito que as crianças se divertirem na
água mas o galo momento teve um grande
evento em que todas as crianças de todas
as idades
e foram fazer uma competição claro que
nessa idade dos 3 anos de idade vai ver
uma competição é uma experiência em
conjunto e num sábado pela manhã todas
as crianças juntas entrando em fila se
posicionaram para dar e antes de um som
tocar pa largada nunca queima de largada
sair antes os outros vão atrás e quem
aquela festa mães e pais gritando hiper
Hiper emocionante Especialmente para
quem está vivendo só que tinha um
detalhe eu não estava lá
eu estava Fernanda está louca Eu estava
mais ou menos 1.200 km de distância
naquele sábado pela manhã em
compromissos profissionais de docência
e naquele ano
e eu viajei de avião 136 vezes eu estava
literalmente na estrada pelo Brasil
entendeu teve um dia e as coisas tinha
que compensar em casa quando eu vou a
viajava muito chique também trabalhar e
produzir em casa um dia nós temos esse
vídeo o Lucas foi filmado pela Fernanda
digitando em frente ao computador e não
sabia detalhes sabe escrever
Oi e a pena perguntar o que está fazendo
filho tô trabalhando mano tô trabalhando
com Essência no teu trabalho
e eu precisava fazer diferente e eu
precisava ser diferente eu comecei a
pensar na Perspectiva temporal mas achei
um pouco mais eficiente naquilo que eu
fazia e também comecei a pensar na
Perspectiva espacial para onde eu quero
ir o que eu quero fazer da minha vida
especialmente Nesse contexto
profissional que tanto tá puxando em
relação ao familiar e como o professor
que sou eu vi que existia um campo de
decisão envolvendo a maneira como eu
praticavam ensino e eu comecei a
mergulhar nessa linha de cursos à
distância foi a dele ele é permanente
porque uma vez produzido o conteúdo ele
está o tempo todo à disposição sete dias
por semana 24 horas por dia o ensino à
distância além de permanente ele também
é síncrono o quê ué sincronismo as
pessoas interagem nem sempre ao mesmo
tempo o conteúdo está Professor produz o
conteúdo ao
e interagem com aquele conteúdo quando o
cliente e por falar em interatividade o
e também tem um plus que nos prometem
aquela possibilidade de fora de
discussão e várias ferramentas que fazem
porque em alguns momentos nós atuamos de
maneira cinco escolhido o ensino a
distância eu pensei traçar uma
estratégia e as estratégias envolvia um
ambiente virtual que metodologicamente
escolhi a plataforma Google classroom
que ela era gratuita e funcionava nas
versões desktop mobile e era novidade na
época eu também me preparei para algo
que me parece um fundamental para quem
pretende ser em cima distância não há
sentido por comunicador uma comunicadora
sair de casa
e para gravar algo produzir algo que vai
ficar à disposição tempo todo para as
pessoas
e faz muito mais sentido você ter um
estúdio em casa e fazer isso em casa eu
como estúdio Eu também escolher um
projeto piloto era um curso preparatório
ou seja curso preparatório para
concursos públicos que pressupõe uma
audiência com muita gana de conhecimento
Essa foto é de um dos quartos no meu
apartamento já em Guarapuava no estado
do Paraná o corte metodológico era fazer
tudo sozinho eu não podia ter ajuda de
ninguém então ali eu aprendi a digitar
vídeos eu aprendi a cortar vídeos não
cabia era um quarto era um quarto
adaptado não cabia por exemplo um quadro
não cabia por exemplo uma TV para passar
slides ou coisa desse tipo então eu tive
que aprender também a fazer captura de
tela e escrever na tela para depois com
os dois vídeos em minha fazer as
sobreposições Eu também aprendi que a
câmera que tá aparecendo ali na imagem
Ela Só grava por 25 minutos ela esquenta
que você tem que parar eu também aprendi
que na hora de você fazer o quê
e daqui busque tão em 4K vocês uma banda
na internet bem maior Eu também aprendi
que o computador que a gente usa que é
típico de texto e de Navegação de
internet ele não tem espaço para guardar
vídeos e nesse aprendizado todo o que eu
posso dizer para vocês que houve muita
evolução muita descoberta e também muita
decepção em termos daquilo que a gente
consegue fazer sozinho Aline do ensino a
distância Eu sou professor de sala de
aula eu sou professor adolescente
Estadual de Ponta Grossa no curso de
direito a quase 15 anos e nesses 15 anos
quase todo tempo eu fui o professor
o tradicional o professor que fala em
quantas pessoas escutam enquanto alunas
e alunos escutam E aí quando a gente
começa a aprender um pouco mais gente
metodologia a gente percebe que vai
fazer um multimídia melhor dá para fazer
uma apresentação PowerPoint melhor e
mesmo assim eu não consegui adesão da
moçada porque tem choque geracional eu
falo hoje com 41 anos de idade mas os
meus alunos têm 17 18 19 em sua grande
maioria e nesse choque geracional chega
o momento que eu pergunto para os meus
alunos mostrada que vocês querem o que
que é importante para vocês o quê que
vocês não gostam no Professor o quê que
vocês gostam no Professor E aí veio uma
riqueza maravilhosa que está
representada nesta foto os meus alunos
disseram Professor Fabrício Eu gosto do
mal lá contextual
o professor Fabrício eu gosto de se
fazer semicírculo eu gosto com dos
alunos falam no diálogo construtivo eu
gosto de ter uma participação que não
seja obrigatória que seja voluntária eu
gosto de experiências práticas e eu
gosto de experiências dinâmicas em sala
de aula uau isso me coloca numa posição
de me reformular como comunicador de
sala de aula revelar o Fabrício buscar o
que as grandes metodologias que o
pessoal da pedagogia sabe de cor e
salteado metodologias ativas e coisas
que a gente pode fazer em termos de
interatividade Real em sala de aula 1
e nesses dois mundos o ensino a
distância com suas metodologias próprias
e o ensino presencial com suas
metodologias próprias E como você
perceber que são mais 7 segundo
estáticos não existe um diálogo entre
metodologia presencial e metodologia de
ensino a distância por exemplo
e eu só comecei a perceber isso não foi
um Insight pessoal veio de um grupo de
alunos e hoje grandes amigos os meus
alunos falaram assim professor Fabrício
o que que você acha que eu começo a
gravar o vídeo para o YouTube Eu tenho
dois passos para trás é eu YouTube 40
anos de idade não eu vou fazer isso não
não sei fazer e eles incentivaram tanto
que nós começamos o canal do YouTube foi
aberto e ele hoje serve
e para depósito de conteúdo da minha
área de trabalho que é o direito nós
sabemos que no YouTube Nós temos duas
opções metodológicas ou você transmite
novo a um ou você transmitir conteúdo a
nossa escolha foi transmitir conteúdo e
essa experiência tem alguns meses e de
iniciando especialmente o que que eu tô
percebendo que graças esse conteúdo
muito que acontece hoje presencialmente
em sala de aula é apoiado Graças algo
que vem do ensino a distância em
conteúdo onipresente em conteúdo
permanente e um conteúdo que foi
meticulosamente pensado para que a
ambiência que é o vídeo digital curto
direto ao ponto Sem Rodeios e com muita
experiência sensorial envolvida e É
nesse momento que eu chama a nossa
atenção prova que eu achei que batizei
de desbloqueio de habilidades a todo
tempo nós estamos desbloqueado
habilidades
e quando você aprende inglês você
desbloqueou essa habilidade e o mundo de
oportunidades aparece para você
E como você aprende a programar por
exemplo sendo de humanas um mundo novo
se descortina para você graça esse
desbloqueio de habilidades pensando em
tudo isso
é o que a gente tem no ensino presencial
e a gente tem as grandes metodologias
ativas que servem para sala de aula Eu
solicitei três para te mostrar que são
construção coletiva de conhecimento onde
todos participam desenvolvimento de
competências em sala de aula para que o
acadêmico acadêmica não saia só com
abstração e sim sabendo produzir algo e
acima de tudo tudo isso envolvendo
experiências práticas que chame atenção
interessa e o grupo
E essas são habilidades típicas do
ensino presencial bombeiro quando a
gente olha por isso uma distância a
gente tem aqui no que eu gostaria de
chamar e batismo de habilidades 4.0
o seu novo as habilidades que nós
estamos pensando apenas o ensino a
distância e que tipo de verdade são
essas quando a gente faz um vídeo no
YouTube por exemplo a gente tem um
roteiro de aula com conteúdo a gente
dizem que cremos corrente Você tem
entrado no vídeo a saída você tem os
vídeos que vocês vão ser sobrepostos
você tem um material que vai ser
entregue você tem mensagens mais
potência Você tem fotos você tem local
interno e externo você cria um script
como você faz uma Cláudia de se criar um
tutorial você pode capturar tela e fazer
transmitir o normal por exemplo pessoal
da Computação não vai ficar falando como
eu tô falando aqui vai capturar a tela e
mostrar como se faz uma programação e
claro a gente tem as interações online
Além disso outras habilidades que podem
ser exploradas podcast upload de
arquivos MP3 para pessoas que não gostam
quero te ver mas ainda não estou no
trânsito e podem ter interesse em te
ouvir videocast no YouTube por
excelência
a ver o Instagram e self-publishing as
editoras nós todos sabemos estão
sofrendo muito com o que ocorre uma
revolução que está acontecendo o seu
Uber chegou para que você eu nós
entregamos as nossas Artes e escritas
em directo a pessoa que tem interesse em
recebê-lo sem intermediários juntando
tudo isso a gente pode encontrar espaço
para uma nova arte de ensino
e o Maggi de ensino que envolva o
desbloqueio de habilidade do mundo
presencial sem
é mas que nós agregamos habilidades do
mundo virtual online o mundo do YouTube
e que nós consigamos um tá tudo isso
naquilo que os franceses chamarem
assemblagem um bom vinho não é só aquele
que vem de uma determinada uva muitas
vezes o bom vinho ele vem
o Don Borges da União da Assunção e
nessa nova Artes
e eu trago exemplo do tijolo porque
misturar porque a gente tem que ter os
dois mundos como uma nova arte e por que
que ela tem potencial porque senão te
perguntar aqui desafiar pensa nas
características do Tijolo
e certamente você vai ter mais ou menos
respostas com essa aqui que usei no
mecanismo única da interatividade online
em tempo real para os meus alunos você
vai dizer que o tijolo é retangular você
vai dizer que eu vejo o tijolo é duro
sólido vermelho mas isto firme Entre
várias características que envolvem a
tua abstração em relação ao tijolo é uma
ideia abstrata Mas a partir do momento
o que eu te passo irmão este tijolo
e com essas características e você tem o
contato sensorial com ele de experiência
a sinestésica ocular sensorial você vai
me dar respostas bem diferentes você vai
mandar Respostas como essas aqui sujo
tenho velho áspero
o frio e várias características que não
fazem parte da situação mas integram por
Excelência a experiência de contato
e é por isso que a gente tem um novo
espaço para uma nova arte como fazer
e se você é professor se você é
professor
é a minha primeira dica para você sai de
cena não pense mais no roteiro
presencial pensa no Script pensa no
conteúdo que não tá só consigo encontro
que tá no mundo e na palma da mão dos
seus alunos um de tudo isso a favor de
todos e deixe de todo mundo interaja e
construa algo diferente preveja que seus
acadêmicos fazem parte do protagonismo
construtivo da aula se você prefere por
exemplo às vezes é necessário o Maurício
positiva então eu digo o seguinte
e faça tô melhor exposição captura em
vídeo essa exposição faça o upload para
o YouTube
a starwood MP3 esse vídeo e faça o
upload para o Spotify por exemplo
a PED disse mesmo áudio e faça o upload
para o Watson da IBM que têm
Inteligência Artificial embutida o ótimo
ele vai te devolver o texto de gravado
inscrito esse riqueza do texto que vem
passar lá o texto escrito que baseado no
artigo científico na texto duro
o abstrato em pessoal o texto que vem da
fala e a gente está tendo essa
experiência o texto que vira fala é rico
Limpo comunicativo e maravilhoso entrega
esse texto aos seus alunos todos vão
evoluir se texto vocês podem produzir
fascículos de livros a cada aula os as
suas vamos que interessam no estudo mais
verticalizado podem produzir artigos
científicos a partir desse material
existe uma riqueza maravilhosa nessa
nova arte de ensino envolvendo os dois
minutos e para responder basicamente
essa pergunta como fazer
e as ferramentas sempre estiveram ao
nosso dispor no mas o bandgap grande
espaço que está diante de nós é nós
ainda não percebemos que temos de ensino
e processo comunicativo nós temos
poderosíssimas ferramentas a nosso
dispor para entregar uma nova arte de em
cima
o motorista e
E aí
[Aplausos]